en la cima de su carrera boris becker lo
tenía todo pero a principios de abril el
gran tenista alemán fue declarado
culpable de cuatro delitos por un juicio
por bancarrota entre ellos ocultaron no
entregar bienes para evitar el pago de
sus deudas el ex número uno del mundo se
declaró en quiebra en 2017 por un
préstamo impagado de más de 35 millones
de euros
becker dijo a los jurados que los 50
millones de dólares que ganó en su
carrera fueron engullidos por un costoso
divorcio pagos de manutención de sus
hijos y los compromisos de un costoso
estilo de vida vivía en una casa
alquilada de 26 mil euros al mes en
wimbledon al suroeste de londres a poca
distancia del all england lawn tennis
and croquet club donde en 1985 se
convirtió en el campeón más joven en
wimbledon en la categoría individual
masculina con 17 años baker pasó a ganar
otros 5 títulos de gran slam antes de
conseguir una serie de otros trabajos
como embajador de marca comentarista
deportivo en televisión y entrenador de
novak djokovic pero también tuvo varios
negocios fallidos y sus ingresos no se
corresponden con su lujoso estilo de
vida
primera vez que becker se ve envuelto en
problemas financieros en 2002 fue
condenado por evasión de impuestos en
alemania pero también debe unos 47
millones de euros a las autoridades
suizas el abogado defensor de baker dijo
a los miembros del jurado que becker era
demasiado confiado y dependiente de sus
asesores financieros pero que también
había un elemento de su tendencia a
enterrar la cabeza en la arena